industry saturday morning at eight
through monday morning at eight eastern
48 hours of non-fiction books all
weekend every weekend on book tv
next on encore book notes former
president jimmy carter
he sat down with us in 1995 to discuss
his first collection of poetry always a
reckoning
in it president carter shares his
private memories about his childhood his
family and political life
it's about an hour
president jimmy carter what's the origin
of the title of your book of poems
always a reckoning
well it's extracted from one of the
lines of a poem about my father
and how he ran our farm and everything
had to balance
there was no
possibility in his mind to have anything
on the farm as i said in the poem
that you couldn't plow or didn't give
milk or you couldn't to get eggs from or
it couldn't uh
find a rabbit or quail
and uh so it meant that my father
required a reckoning from all those who
worked on the farm or whatever and i
think it's
kind of applicable to life in general
when you
you put an investment in something you
get back a dividend so i said it's kind
of like an ocean wave going in and out
how long has your father been gone
daddy died in 1953.
he had cancer he was 59 years old
he was a member of the state legislature
and a very fine
very stern disciplinarian
who
he was honored in his community
who i think loved me very much
he was quite reticent about
indicating his affection
and who has always been one of my heroes
have you done things differently with
your kids because of the way your dad
was with you you know i don't think i
did until
my children got up
a little bit older and began to to be
much more verbal in their criticism of
the way i treated them i was a very i
was a naval officer for 11 years and i
was a very stern disciplinarian when i
told my three boys to do something they
did it
if they didn't they suffered uh the
consequences
and then
we waited uh about 15 years and amy came
along but i never was nearly that stern
with amy and and my rationalization is
that she didn't really need to be
chastised
and and i
in another appointment i wrote
i want to be part of my father's world
that to that extent oh
i realized
when i was an adult and had sons of my
own and was at my father's
bedside during his death
that there was a surprising parallel
between my father's
relationship to me which i resented very
much on occasion
and my relationship with my sons and i
saw that my father had implanted in me
not only
habits and attitudes but also i guess
genetic material that
that mirrored himself in me and
i wrote one of my most difficult poems
about that
where are your what you have four kids
yes i have four children where are they
amy is in graduate school she's just
moved to new orleans she's going to
transfer to either tulane or to new
orleans university she's in fine arts
she's finished her undergraduate work
she's a painter and a very good one i
think my youngest son jeffrey is a
graduate of george washington university
here with a degree
in geography and in computer programming
he's one of the most advanced computer
program designers
in our country he has three uh sons
uh chip is an international finance
chief deals
deals in establishing funding for
interesting projects
in
strange places like china and chiapas
mexico things of that kind chief has two
children the oldest of whom was born
a month after i moved into the white
house and she was living in the white
house then
and then jack the oldest son
has four children one uh two of his
own with his first wife and two
children step children one of whom did
the illustrations for the book
um so the actual jack's living in san
francisco so we have a very good family
let me show an illustration because all
of your poems have an illustration and
here's one that leads off and the poem
was called rachel
tell us who did these illustrations and
then we can talk about rachel
well all of the illustrations in the
book were done by my 16 year old
granddaughter sarah
who has a summer job on the streets in
telluride colorado ski resort
by making quick sketches of people's
faces
and she uh
did these line drawings just black and
white line drawings when she did this i
don't think she'd ever seen a mule but
uh sarah
drew the uh
black and white sketches after she read
the poems it's kind of a 16 year old
interpretation or impression of the of
the book this is a a hunting scene
there again
she read the poem and
decided to draw a scene of what she
envisioned to be a hunting scene where
did you get the idea to have her do the
illustrations
i i thought first about getting a
professional illustrator to do them
because i kind of wanted an illustration
for it for each one but uh
i realized that sarah was a very
accomplished uh young artist and
embryonically
this one is about my mother who was in
the peace corps and who
was uh faced with a very unpleasant
prospect of doctoring
a little girl with leprosy
she was a registered nurse she reacted
against that very strongly and the poem
was about is distracted really from a
letter that i received from my mother
when she was 70 years old
in the peace corps near bombay india
this is
an illustration showing what a
registered nurse
might mean the the cap of a registered
nurse back in the 1930s and 40s and the
emblem of of our
rn our registered nurse where did you
put the originals
i think at this moment the originals are
with random house of times books and i
need to get all the originals back to
make sure that we have them in my in my
own archives
sarah
struggle with some of them you know
she's never seen a meal and she'd never
seen a barn
and uh
one of the things is about a peanut
picker she'd never seen a peanut picker
she was a city girl from cleveland ohio
now moved to san francisco and so she
had to use her own imagination about
what some of the things looked like but
i think the fact that they are
all unrehearsed and uh and just simple
are very good this is about my sister
who was an avid motorcyclist
who
was a hostess
for a bunch of rough
motorcycle
drivers who would stop at her house on
the way to daytona every year
and
when my sister died
the bikers came into planes and stayed
with her
at her bedside for
several uh days before her death and and
in during her funeral
uh they formed a motorcycle cortage in
front
there were 37 motorcycles one harley
davidson they had to be harley-davidson
in front and then 36 behind it
and on her tombstone airplanes there's
an inscription she rides in harley
heaven she was very
deeply committed to
cycling that was ruth carter's statement
that was gloria gloria
yes that's my oldest sister
also didn't she have cancer if i
remember all my family have died with
cancer they all smoke cigarettes i'll
die with cancer my father my mother my
two sisters and my brother all of them
i'm the last one left and uh have you
stopped smoking i never have started
and they all smoked
they all smoked yes what impact did the
fact that all of these people have you
lost them and especially your father
real early and your sister in a fairly
early age what impact did that have on
you
it was a sobering experience obviously
they you know they passed away one at
the time
my father first and back in 1953
and then my mother lived to be
in her early 80s
my brothers and sisters all died fairly
young but it was a very sobering
experience
strangely enough
they all had pancreatic cancer
which was formerly thought to be like
one out of 1500 people die with
pancreatic cancer so it's beyond the
realm of mathematical probability that
everybody in the family would die with
it
but now the american cancer society
is doing a special study on our family
to see if there is not a familial
inherited trait
that causes the incidence of pancreatic
cancer
so every three or four months i have a
special test to run on my
body
to see if i am
becoming afflictivist with pancreatic
cancer
you have a
i'm trying to find it here a poem in
here
about um i'm probably too far
in this uh
in the book but it's a it's a i'll get
you started on talking about it's a poem
about uh the end of your life and a
bunch of professors
oh yeah that's right
what's the what's the point
that's one of the stories two three
humorous poems and that's one of them
well
we were trying to analyze the uh
impact on the carter center
and its relationship with emory
university when i was uh when i was dead
and we got a group of scholars at emory
to analyze how the university would
treat the carter center after i was no
longer there and they couldn't bring
themselves to to use any sort of frank
language
about my
being dead
so they finally
derived the euphemism
that uh
my uh level of participation would be
reduced and did you hear them talking
about this no they had came out in a
written off in a written report a
document to the president of the
university
and and they couldn't bring themselves
to say when he passes away or when he's
gone or anything like that well at the
end of the poem you say here i now dead
have recently reduced my level of
participation that's that was the
euphemism i used all the way through
instead of saying when he's dead
they said when his level of
participation is reduced
so just to kid them
i wrote the first version of this poem
and just sent it to them as a you know
it's a funny thing and then i decided
well it's an interesting uh concept i'll
just make a poem well and in this
sketch by your granddaughter right here
i assume is the carter family who you
leave standing around your gravesite
well it's it's a maybe a a preacher and
uh
with part of a
funeral ceremony you know there are a
lot of
very nice things you could say pass on
to the heavenly reward or
going to meet his maker or
no longer with us or having passed away
but they couldn't these professors
couldn't even bring themselves to say
that i was going to pass away or go to
meet my heavenly award or go to meet my
maker they just said my level of
participation would be reduced
with you being a former president do you
have to think about your eventual
departure more than most people would
well as a matter of fact my wife and
some of my staff do because they work
out a very uh complete
funeral ceremony plans in advance i
we've really kind of inherited what
president ford has uh has done
and
so there are some things that that you
have to decide before president's demise
before the president's uh former
president's level of participation is
reduced
so that you can handle that in an
orderly fashion so there's a lot of
there are a lot of plans that have to be
made is that hard to do i haven't been
uh participating in it
i've let my wife be the ultimate judge
on what should be done and there's a
there's a professional staff
uh
associate associate i think with the
marine corps who know the history of
presidential funerals and processions
and the display of the body and
how much is done within the capitol
building and how much is done
different places
is your family by the way buried in
plains
yes
my first ancestor buried there was born
in 1798
and rosen's first ancestor was born in
1787
and since then almost all of us have
been born and dead born and died in
plains
there's um
also in here a poem about your ancestors
and the civil war yes that's true what's
that i'll find it while you talk about
it
it's a it's a poem that derived from um
letters that i found in an old trunk
where
the report comes back from the
battlefront
one of my uh
in in my great let's see great
grandfather's generation
they had a um
a platoon of a company of soldiers that
left my county 126 members
and when they went to savannah and still
had about that many when he wrote the
letter they only had 36 members left
and he wrote a letter that ended i
thought in an intriguing way he said
i am well
but not satisfied
which i thought was a a nice line to you
so i built a poem around that
the more things change then you have
this this illustration right here what
is this the illustration is of an old
trunk
uh that that i guess is all over the
south and i guess the north too where
people store the uh
letters off their ancestors from the
civil war what kind of poetry is this
and you know do you study poetry and all
the different kinds
are they all the same kind of poetry no
i think they are varied
uh beginning about five years ago i
studied um
textbooks about poetry and the different
kinds of poetry the different kinds of
media and
and whether they rhymed or not open
verse and so forth
and and also poetry books that analyzed
uh what famous poets were
uh
saying and and how they said it and the
words they chose
my favorite poet uh of all times is
dylan thomas but i don't
have any
uh ability or inclination to try to
emulate his poetry
i think in general the poems are fairly
simple in structure but they don't rhyme
most of them
some of them rhyme in a subtle way you
have to kind of look for the rhymes
slant rhymes or kind of off-rhymes
a few of them have a more more obvious
rhyming but when i first started i felt
that every poem had to rhyme
and i and i soon got away from that
and uh and then
on at times i just make the last two or
three
lines have some sort of rhyme and
some of the later poems don't rhyme at
all
uh one of the things i'm discovering is
how hard it is to find a poem the dylan
thomas one uh there's one we write about
dylan thomas at westminster
yes in westminster abbey when i was
president i went over to west to london
for the
summit conference
economic summit conference
and i wanted dylan thomas had always
been my hero in the portrait field i
thought he was the best poet of all
i wanted to go to lauren in in wales to
visit his uh home place
and
uh
something happened the prime minister
asked me to go to newcastle upon the
time instead so i had to skip my visit
to wales then
i've been since so i went to westminster
abbey and i asked the archbishop who was
my host i was president of the united
states
i had a group of white house reporters
following me around
always
and i asked him where dylan thomas
stone was and he said oh we we couldn't
have dylan thomas uh commemorated here
you know he was a drunkard and so forth
and i said well look there's lord byron
you know who's gay there's so
there's that gallant who was a drug
addict you've got other people here why
not dylan thomas i think he's the
greatest portrait of this century
so i went back
to the white house and i wrote a letter
to the
screening committee or whatever you call
it
at westminster abbey and told them why i
thought dylan thomas should be included
and uh
it was almost four years later before
they finally accepted dylan thomas to be
honored in the porch corner in
westminster abbey they asked me to come
over for the ceremonies and i and i was
unable to go it was a few few months
after i left the white house i wasn't
doing any traveling
so bbc came over and interviewed me in
depth about dylan thomas the reporter
was quite skeptical
about my knowledge of dylan thomas so he
asked me all kinds of questions and i
answered them and he asked me to to
quote a few lines from the dylan thomas
poems which i was certainly able to do
and so they played that tape at the
dedication ceremonies and later a group
of people came from wales over to
georgia and brought me a replica of the
dylan thomas stone that's in the floor
at westminster abbey
caitlyn
dylan thomas wife by the way read the
news reports
from that trip to westminster abbey and
wrote me a nice letter thanking me for
for
mentioning her husband
when was the first time you proposed to
your publisher
that you do a book of poems
i was about four years ago
and they said no
no way
that they didn't think
they wanted to publish
a poetry book by me
and they said that my poems that i
submitted were not uh
suitable for a book
so
so i backed away for a while
as a matter of fact i didn't back
exactly back away i took a
a poem out of a current
issue of new york or magazine
which to me was completely
garbled i mean there was no redeeming
feature that i could see in this point
it didn't make sense it didn't have any
rhyme it was not beautiful the choice of
words was not
notable and so i cut the point out and
sent it to the publisher
of
random house times books
and i told them if new yorker could
publish a poem like that
i saw no reason why they couldn't
publish my portrait book but i didn't
push it anymore but later i felt that i
got three or four poems
in a
final form
and i began to send my poems to
different periodicals around the country
to quarterlies and to monthly magazines
dedicated to poetry
and some of them are rejected and some
are more accepted
i ask them not to comment on the fact
that i was a former president just to
put my name and not even say who it was
and uh increasingly
the poems got favorable reviews from you
know inside those
those
places
and i've eventually got up the nerve to
uh
to put
about 45 poems together and then when i
resubmitted them
to the publisher
they offered me a minuscule advance
and decided to take a chance on the vote
where's this
painting from on the cover of the book
that's a painting an original painting
by a very fine georgia
artist named butler brown
when butler discovered it that i was
going to have a book of poems he offered
to do the cover painting for me
and i think it's very very nice it's
funny where is it
where's where's the painting i mean
where's the location that he painted
what is this i think it's just a rural
scene from metal georgia from about
where plains is
and it commemorates the way the
countryside may have been when many of
the poems were written what are you
going to do with the original painting
i'll it'll either be in my home i'll
have to call the sun
now where was this picture taken on the
back of the book that was taken at the
carter center when uh
when i was
when they finally decided to to do the
book and they were just looking for
a back cover and they this is one
they've used in the advertisements in
new york times and then the new yorker
magazine and others
where did you write these poems mostly
at home
in planes yes
that my word processor
some of them i would write
to a great degree
on trips
in airplanes or other places when i was
away from home
but the final
versions
most of which
well maybe
20
generations away from the original
version
would usually done on my word processor
are there any presidents in history that
wrote poems other than you
i have heard it said that john quincy
adams and abraham lincoln wrote points
but i've never seen i have never seen
any of their poems
and and i've asked two or three people
lately who were portrait critics if they
had
read the poems of the two previous
presidents and they said no but that's
been a story that has gone around that
that abraham lincoln and john quincy
adams did write poems i don't know in
the front of the book you list all the
other books that you have written and i
counted
eight um and i remember why not the best
which was that's the first one put out
around the time you run for president
yes i wrote that in 1975
how many of these do you write entirely
yourself
eight
every word every word it's all yours
every word is it easy hard how would you
describe it
some of them have been very difficult
the the book blood of abraham i had to
do a lot of research on on what was
happening
in the middle east all the way from the
time of abraham
down to the present time and i actually
went to the middle east and interviewed
all the israeli leaders and the leaders
in in lebanon and the palestinian
leaders and the leaders in syria and
jordan and so forth that was a very
difficult book keeping faith which i
wrote as a memoir
i had when i left the white house about
six thousand
i had about six thousand pages of
typewritten diary notes
and i had to go through and for the
first time looked at those notes
and extracted from them a history of my
four years in the white house
combined with the official history all
the things that were publicized
that was a laborious process but the
book was a very very good seller and
then um
my most enjoyable book
was outdoor journal where i kept a
record of
climbing mountains and then learning how
to
fly fish and some of the experiences
that i had in the outdoors which is my
favorite place to be
so there were varying degrees of
difficulty
turning point
described one of the historical moments
in our country where
we
derived the benefits from the one-man
one-vote ruling and in effect wiped out
what we call the county unit system at
home which was the basis of white
supremacy
vote and democratic party supremacy
and and that that was a book that was a
difficult one to write so
they've been very this has been the most
difficult i think of all i put more time
on this book than any other
in fact since i published this book
since i started writing this book i've
published two other books one is turning
point i just mentioned the other one is
talking peace
talking peace is a is a very important
book i think for young people it's
written for college students and for
advanced high school students the
origins of war a tabulation of all
existing conflicts in the world
and a fairly good uh description of
negotiating or mediating techniques and
how that applies not only to the
resolution of armed conflicts between
nations but also even tensions or armed
conflicts
between kids on the school grounds and
what might be done about it so
if we found you in
the spot
where you were writing we'd find you at
your home in plains yes in front of a
word processor exactly what time of day
do you start this process five o'clock
a.m
i'm much more productive very early in
the morning so when i have a appointment
i can't make come together or a word i
can't
think of or or how to juxtapose two
words that
that fit
uh
my mind is much clearer
i'd say between five and eight o'clock
in the morning and i generally have
breakfast derozan talk about things of a
day when we are at home
and then i work on the word process of
maybe three or four more hours that day
maybe six or seven hours during the day
i can do that much and then my mind kind
of stops working well
and i have a very nice uh woodworking
shop
about 20 feet from my computer
so i go out and build a piece of
furniture or go out to my farm i walk in
the woods i'll do something of that kind
how much time do you have you know those
of us that see you through the eyes of
the news broadcast get the impression
that you're always going somewhere
traveling negotiating or whatever but
how much time do you actually end up
spending then in this kind of world and
planes and quiet and where you're
writing
i would say at the most two or three
days a week
uh we try to be home when we can on the
weekends
uh when i am in plains i teach sunday
school and i
make a lesson outline and last year
out of the 52 sundays i was there 36
times about two out of three sundays the
rest of time
uh we might be in
bosnia or a country in africa or
in russia or
or somewhere else working on
carter center projects
in the um dedication
out front in this book you start off
with a dedication to your father then
your mother then rosalind and then to
rachel clark yes and we started earlier
by showing that rachel clark
illustrations you say whose dignity and
grace were heightened
by a world in which although apartheid
reigned she even managed to excel
into others of her race and mine who
suffer now from prejudice and back then
were forced by law and threats to
tolerate their plight in silence who is
she
rachel clark was a very small
queen-like black woman
who lived
as our next door neighbor
and she was
had an extraordinary impact on my life
she was
a friend when my mother and father would
go off on vacation which they would at
least once a year for a week or two
they were avid baseball fans and their
vacations
consisted entirely
of going either to chicago or new york
or philadelphia or st louis
where there would be a
doubleheader and a series of baseball
games
and that was their
main
enjoyment in life while they were going
away i stayed with rachel clark and her
husband jack clark
she was
she alive no she died recently she was
92 years old and died within the last
few years
but she had a lot of impact on me and
and she would take me fishing and she
would teach me how to pick cotton morph
rapidly and she would kind of help me in
my row if i was getting behind and
she was kind of a philosopher and
she was so
confident she was she could out work and
outperform anyone on the farm
and she was so queenly in her demeanor
although she was very small and
and very quiet
none of the white people even
considered
asking her to do menial labor
they would not ask her
to clean up their homes or to cook for
them or to take care of their children
or to wash clothes and things of that
kind she just and but she'd never would
didn't have to refuse but there was
something special about her
and and people from all around i guess
maybe
five miles
around all knew
about rachel clark
she could pick more cotton
in a day than anyone else
she could whole
cotton and peanuts or corn better than
anyone she could stack more
more peanuts on
for curing than anyone else she was just
a superb person
and and and that's why i wanted that
poem to be the first one in the book and
the longest and it's the longest i think
yes and at the end you say in later
years i'd visit rachel's home in public
housing where
in plains
her husband died her mother who was
named tamer
a biblical name died for rachel is too
of course
and rachel moved into the government
housing project in plains and she lived
alone
respected and almost revered by people
that knew her
and she would walk around the street
and when i went home from the white
house
one of the first things i always did was
you know to kiss my mother and so forth
then i'd go and find rachel
and share experiences she always had
some advice for me
i was president and i mentioned it very
subtly in the last line in washington
where i was working then that means a
white house
a poem later the county boss explains
how it is in the middle of this poem and
by the way what's this what's this
illustration right here that's a barn
burning
and when sarah drew that i don't think
sarah had ever seen a barn
but it's uh
one of the threats that this county boss
had made to enforce his will was
was that anyone who disagreed with him
or who didn't vote his way their barns
would likely burn down
in the middle of this poem you have this
this
sentence politics is hard
yes would you like to explain that
well i'm quoting the county voice you
know
but he what he's saying is that he has
to run that county and he claims he runs
it in a benevolent way and that all the
accusations against him for fraud and
for stealing votes are
unjustified
but if people don't agree with him
they'll suffer the
consequences do you agree with that
politics is hard well politics is hard
it's a brutal
it's a brutal environment
but also gratifying
when were you most gratified
i guess when i won the election to be
president or when i was elected governor
my my most uh
i guess my most my far most difficult
election was when i ran for the state
senate the first time and i wrote an
entire book about this that's when we
had the one man one vote rolling
here's one that
to one now gone who always let his
hunting partner claim a downed bird
yes
i guess among my best friends in the
world was a top leader in the city of
atlanta whose father was a famous mayor
ivan allen
ivan allen was my hunting partner he was
a generous
person who
would always try to take upon himself
the troubles and burdens of his friends
he was very helpful to me every time i
got in trouble
amazingly a couple of years ago ivan
allen took his own life
and i wrote that poem at the time
and i tried to explain that there was
something special about this man
and only after the book came out did i
share the
poem with his family i sent them a copy
of the book and told them to look on
that page
but it's uh
what was their reaction
beautiful
they
his wife margaret wrote me a letter of a
very emotional
letter how much
how much the appointment to her
at the end you say there has to be a
special place for him who held in more
than who held in more than he could bear
to shield the rest of us from care a
rarity who showed us what a gate means
well that's why i said that because i
was asking people before we started how
do you pronounce that and i got a gape
and i want to ask you what agape means
agape use it more than once yes
agape is one of the greek words for love
in the greek language there are four
words for love in fact uh
cs lewis wrote an entire book called the
four loves
agape love is unselfish love
it's love without recompense it's love
for an unlovable person
it's sacrificial love it's kind of love
that jesus christ exemplified in his own
life and i think that ivan alan my
friend showed his friends what
uh agape love man you use it more than
once in your poems oh really i didn't
remember there's another time or you may
maybe in the introduction yeah perhaps
um
the ballad of tom gordy yes
that's a true story by the way and and a
very interesting story
my uncle tom gordy my mother's youngest
brother was in the u.s navy he was on
the island of guam
when the japanese captured guam a month
after pearl harbor
and he was taken prisoner
his wife and three children came down to
live with us in georgia they were from
san francisco
and all during the war they stayed there
in georgia
after two years
the red cross notified
dorothy tom's wife that he was dead
and when she got that horrible news she
moved back to san francisco
almost all of her family were firemen
and after about a year
she remarried a family friend
at the end of the war they found tom
alive
he had been made to work
on a railroad
a 12 mile long railroad that hauled coal
from a mine down to a central railroad
point
and he was emaciated he had been beaten
and abused he only weighed 85 pounds he
was suffering
severely from
from
leviticus of varicose veins
and he came back in a debilitated state
my mother and tom's other sisters and
his and his mother convinced tom
that dorothy had been unfaithful to him
although she married a year after she
was informed he was dead
and tom was too weak i think to overcome
that influence of his family
so
she offered to have the marriage
annulled and
tom refused
to do so her second marriage announced
and eventually he remarried and they
both lived a very happy life toward the
end
but when i was a young submarine officer
in edmond island near san francisco i
went and found
her family
and and i went up and knocked on the
door i had a wife frozen and one child
only then
and i and i left my wife and jack my
oldest son
two blocks away so they could see the
door i didn't know what was going to
happen when i knocked on the door
i did knock on the door and they
there was an uproarious
celebration that i would come and visit
them
uh as tom's nephew
and that that's what the last uh it's
written uh
as you can see in a and a in a ballad
it's only ballad in the uh in the book
what's the what's a ballad
about it i think is a four verse or kind
of uh rhythm that that you can sing
like like an ancient epic poem
and when did you write it
i wrote it about three years ago three
or four years ago i mean did you go
through this i mean what 44 45 poems in
here and you say you started this a
couple of years ago did you go back i
started about five years ago did you
call experiences in your life back
and then start to write a poem i mean
how did you decide what to write about
well i guess i started poems in kind of
spurts
if i had a day or two at home which is
not all that often
then i would try to think of some things
that i wanted to express
that i thought were interesting or that
were heartfelt and i was um
and then i would concentrate on those
poems for a while three or four poems
and
revise them and put them on
put them aside
when i remembered it i would print up a
copy off my computer
you know to get a version and i guess
about 20 of those poems
i have all the the
the intermediary phases of it from the
original thoughts to the final version
and and someday i'll put those in the
presidential library so historians can
see
you know how a former president wrote
forms
but uh
but then i would
read them to rosen i would share them
with miller williams and jim whitehead
who were experts at poetry
they would give me advice on what was
wrong with the point primarily this line
doesn't work or
all this all the performance has extra
words in it or this word doesn't fit and
then i would revise that point
would you tell us more about jim
whitehead and i know
jim white and miller williams are in the
dedication yes who are they
when i came home from the navy um i'm
going to shoot when i came home from the
white house
my brother billy had uh had some friends
from arkansas
and from tennessee one of them was was
tom t hall
who is a well-known country
uh songwriter and singer
and tom t hall had two poetry friends
from the university of arkansas one was
miller williams who was i think was port
of the year in 1990 and jim whitehead
he's also a well-known poet and they
came down and billy had asked them to to
write a poem
about me and my presidency so he had a
party we all had a good time and each
one of those poets read their poem about
me both of which have been published in
their book since then
later um
billy died
and his wife civil opened a cafe and in
order to publicize the cafe to some
degree
she had tom t and the two poets and a
few other people come down and do
readings
and invited about 200 people to come in
and listen to the poetry reading in
plains georgia
and uh while we were eating supper i
talked to
to whitehead and miller williams
and told them that i was
infatuated with poetry and had been for
many years but didn't know anything
about how to write poetry i'd been to
engineering schools and
and done my graduate work in nuclear
physics i didn't have much background in
literature
it turned out that miller williams is a
co-author
of one of the most widely used textbooks
on
on poetry writing in colleges called how
does a poem mean
and
they agreed to send me a copy of that
book so i began to study that and got
some other books about poetry writing
and that's how i got started but they
are the ones with whom i've shared
i've shared my poems and they've given
me advice the only thing i haven't ever
let them do is to write anything for me
they can only
give me negative uh suggestions you know
they say this line doesn't work or this
poem is too long or the rhythm is awful
this word doesn't fit
and they've encouraged me to go back and
and not only look at the current
day
usage of a word
but also the original derivation of a
word what is its uh original meaning and
does that original meaning fit
the expression of the of the word in a
point
so they they forced me to re-examine my
own
my own poetry
you also in the dedication
um and for a short book this is the long
dedication with a lot of names
uh did you think that out by the way
what about how why you used so many
names for the dedication was that on
purpose well you know i could have
written
the dedication actually the dedication
is read is written in iambic uh
emphasis
rhythm
if you read it you can read it like
poetry and i could have put it in in
in open verse form but
um
i could have thanked all of these people
who had an influence on my life
in prose but i decided to do it in the
dedication
uh
in this form
two pages and we're just showing the
audience what the two pages look like uh
one other
member on this list that i want to ask
you about is hyman rickover yes who was
he and what influence did he have on you
except for my own father hyman rickover
had more influence on me than any other
man i've ever known
when i was a young naval officer i was
in submarines
what year
i went into submarines in 1948
i had to wait two years after i finished
annapolis i was in law then
and i served in submarines
on a fleet type boat and then i helped
i was the first officer assigned to the
first ship the navy ever built after the
second world war a little killer
submarine and there's a poem written
about life on the killer submarine
and then i went to work for rickover as
i was in charge of the crew that built
the second atomic submarine
and rickover was
not dissimilar from my father
rickover demanded
my utmost effort
and uh
never was constrained to congratulate me
when i did a good job but was eager to
point out my shortcomings and defects
and he
inspired me to do
better things with my with my life than
i would otherwise have done
the first book i ever wrote in 1975 why
not the best was was the titleist
derived from my first interview with
rickover
was he tough there's no way to describe
how tough he was yes and and i think
that
the chief executive officer general
electric
company was just as uh nervous when
rickover was on the way disconnected in
new york as i was
recover was very tough but fair i think
the finest engineer has ever lived
and personally responsible for the
evolution of nuclear power as a peaceful
peacetime use does
the personal toughness of an individual
does that work
i mean did
he scare you
yeah he scared me i mean have you ever
used that with others
my three sons say that i used it with
them
but usually i'm a lot more easygoing
than that and certainly with advanced as
advancing age i've become a lot more
mellow in my attitude toward others
and uh i would think that most people
would say that i have a general approach
to other folks now
but this being tough work
i think so in a in a in a final
mediation or negotiation you have to be
extremely tough you have to know exactly
how far you can go and go no further
and uh and you have to use the maximum
degree of persuasion to induce
a recalcitrant recalcitrant party to
accept your proposal yes i think you
have to be tough
a poem here
with this illustration by your
granddaughter you say is now
17 yes she going to go on to be a
professional i think she's still she's
in a very advanced high school in san
francisco
that has a very good art department so i
don't have any doubt about it by the way
that poem is the only sonnet in the poem
i found it very difficult to write a
sonnet what's a sonnet a sonnet is a
classical format for a poem that was
used repeatedly by shakespeare and which
is a
as a very specific uh
frame work both uh for emphasis on words
and rhythm and length of lines and they
and the style of rhyming
it's a it's a rigid form that can't be
from which you cannot deviate i still
call it the sonnet
i can still remember and i'd love to you
can tell me where i can find this a memo
that was written by ham jordan
in 19
tell me if i'm wrong about this 72 in
december
it ended up in a book that i remember
reading that laid out your campaign
in which planes was kind of like the
staging area
uh
do you remember that memo well i
remember the memo i didn't realize it
had been published in a book though i
think marty sram had a book out well he
might have well you know there were
probably 30 books written about that
remarkable campaign
and maybe that marty schramm didn't
quote from it i didn't remember that can
anybody ever do that again use a small
town in a place like georgia and
well hope arkansas is not much yeah but
he didn't go back there all the time no
i didn't didn't have uh trailers with
network cameras well planes you know is
is now and always has been the center of
my life when i was even in the navy you
know i there was a magnet pulling me
back to planes as i said earlier
both my ancestors and roseanne's who
were born in the 1700s are buried there
and we've
we've got the same land that's been in
our family since 1832.
and
you know in our both of our families are
there
so there's a strong magnetism pulling us
back to play so plains is the center of
our life
and i don't i doubt it that very many
people in this modern fast changing
technological mobile world
has that uh intensity of attraction to a
small town where a husband and a wife
both are from there and feel compelled
you know pleasantly to go back how far
is it from atlanta
by airplane it's 120 miles exactly to
south by road it's about 130 miles it
takes what how long to drive well we
allot three hours to go from planes to
the carter center and that allows
one one stop to go the restroom and
without rushing
to go from from planes to the airport we
a lot uh two hours and a half
if one travels if someone goes to planes
right now to see you or to see the town
what's there
that picture in the uh and the sonnet is
exactly what's there now it's what was
there in 1900 do you own that thing's
there now still do you still have them
i own i own yes i own all the land that
we've ever owned a couple of thousand
acres and we own a house on a farm
that's that's just barely inside the
city limits of plains is there a tour
that one takes now yes there is
people telling you that jimmy carter is
from here exactly yes it's run at the
park services uh plains is now
a national historical site and this park
service is developing
some of the tourist attractions there
but there's a there's a guy that that
owns billy carter's old service station
who uh who has a tour i think it costs
five bucks
and you can go around and visit 20
different sites and planes that have
something to do with me or family
what's this illustration about that's a
illustration from a poem called peanuts
that describes life in a small town
during the 1930s
and
that's me with a bag of
with a basket full of peanuts that i'm
taking to planes to sell i used to walk
down the railroad track about two miles
and a half
to planes and sell 20 bags of peanuts
for a total of a dollar and then brought
back home let me read this paragraph
okay almost ignored an omnipresent boy i
learned how merchants cheat
which married men laid half a dollar
[ __ ] not always white
the same ones touting racial purity and
klansmen sheeted bravery at night
what's that all about
well that's actually a fact
in the first place as a five six seven
year eight eight-year-old boy
omnipresent on the plane streets every
day
the adults
learned just to ignore my presence
and they would say things and do things
as though i was not there
and some of the men would uh would talk
about their sexual exploits
or some of the ones that were more
i'd say disreputable or whatever
would brag about going down to albany
georgia 35 miles away to a whorehouse
and having sex with [ __ ]
some of whom were white some of whom
were black and the same men would be the
ones most likely to be
mentioned as members of the ku klux klan
and this was
the an unpleasant facet of the plane's
city life
at that time planes had about 500 people
total population
has uh
has all that gone away
so far as i know it's all gone away
except the physical plot town is there
and it's a little bit larger as a matter
of fact in total population that was
back then
um
one of the last lines here is long
before i was 10 years old i learned to
judge the whole community yes
how has that followed you through your
life
well you didn't read the rest of it i
was kind of human
i knew the good folks were the ones who
bought their boiled peanuts for me
well i i you know one time during the
campaign i said that
that's interesting i can't wait till the
to the psychiatrist get hold of this
book but one time during the campaign i
was making a funny statement i said you
know
it's not good for us to judge people i
think i said it in a church
i said
but i know how to judge people i learned
how to judge people when i was eight
years old i used to sell boiled peanuts
in plains and i very quickly learned how
to judge everybody in town
the good people were the ones that
bought boiled peanuts for me and the bad
people didn't it was a joke
but later two psychiatrists got hold of
that
quote
and just
i could judge people about whether they
they did me favors you know
so i i'm sure that when when
psychiatrists get a hold of this uh
or psycho politicians or whatever they
call them says get hold of this series
of poems they're going to have a field
day are you all surprised by the
reaction to the book of poems so far
pleasantly surprised
yeah the reviews have been beautiful
well the only negative comment i made in
an otherwise very good overall piece i
think it was a newsweek
the uh uh critics said that uh
that i shouldn't have included the poem
to roseland because it was so
personal and emotional that it that in
effect it embarrassed him to read it but
but that has turned out to be
i think the favorite poem in the whole
book
when i signed books and i signed
maybe 1500 to 2000 at each bookstore
a lot of the people will open
the book to a certain point and ask me
to sign it there instead of on a fly
leaf
and
a surprising portion of the women want
me to sign the roseland
point
here's a
a reflection of the beauty in washington
but it's the illustration that i also
want to show has your granddaughter been
here often
i don't think she's ever been here
so how does she figure out to do
something like well she knows she knows
what the
capitol looks like actually i was in the
white house
and they were on the roof of the white
house i think the white house shows up
at yes
and i think the poem is one of the most
beautiful of all it's
it's a very simple poem
about our going to the roof of the white
house one night my youngest son was an
amateur astronomer
and he wanted us to look at a
constellation
and
we were aggravated because
you couldn't see the stars very clearly
because of the washington city lights
and all of a sudden we heard this
primeval
sound coming from the north
and there was a beautiful flight of
geese going over washington and the city
lights were being reflected from their
breasts
and it was one of the most memorable and
beautiful sights i've ever seen and
that's what i wrote the poem about
you have a phone poem that has the
heading some things i love and
things like my in basket empty
a good new book yes now fiction
nonfiction both
best book you've read in the last few
months
most interesting
well uh uh the not the fiction book i've
read recently i liked it by a danish
writer and smile and her knowledge of
the snow
ice and snow
i think that one of the most interesting
non-fiction books i've read recently is
the quark and the jaguar which is a a
book about scientific discoveries
and the recent book about franklin and
eleanor roosevelt i found to be
interesting
the end of a six mile run in the rain
that's right some things i love yes why
you still run yes i ran this morning
sure
i run whenever possible when we're
traveling overseas my wife and i run
every morning quite early we get up
early we run
uh when it gets daybreak and uh we
generally get through before sunrise
and then we can go through the rest of
the day on you know in restaurants and
in meetings and on airplanes and we
still enjoy running grandchildren coming
in our front door the same ones leaving
in a day or two
what what
[Music]
what's the best thing that somebody can
say about you the best thing what do you
like what you know as you travel around
i'm sure people say
things to your face that you like to
hear and maybe some things you don't
like to hear but what's the what do you
want to i don't want to say be
remembered by but what do you what do
you like
the most well i don't know it's hard to
say
oh i think historically i'd like to be
remembered for things that we did
that contributed to peace and human
rights
i'd like
people to
understand it that i've
been honest and
truthful
uh and that i've loved the simplest
things of life i'd like for
to be remembered as a good grandfather
we have nine grandchildren you know
there's a wide range of things i'd like
to be remembered for i was an
outstanding farmer
at one time i produced the best seed
peanuts i think in this country perhaps
in the world i was very proud of that i
was a good submarine also so yeah the
different phases in my life i've been
i've wanted to be remembered for
different things
plan to write another book
i'm writing another book right now and
as i say i put it i've published two
books since this one was begun
uh whether i'll have a uh
have another book of poetry i don't yet
know
i've got seven or eight poems now that
are in the development stage
and so i continue to write poetry i
really enjoy this
i've been amazed really at how
uh much of a self-revelation comes from
a poem
you know i i start writing a poem about
things that that i want to treat
superficially in a way
and before i know it i've
kind of exploring the the inner depth of
my soul and my consciousness and my
memory and
and
revealing things that otherwise i would
never have told anyone
this is what the cover of the book looks
like
a book of poems always a reckoning
by jimmy carter thank you very much for
your time i've enjoyed it very much
you've been watching a 1995 encore book
notes interview with former president
jimmy carter his first book of poetry
always a reckoning is published by
random house for more information visit
their website randomhouse.com
next week on encore book notes winston s
churchill the grandson of sir winston
churchill sat down with us